IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT'S HASHTAG WARS!
(cheers and applause)
THIRSTY THURSDAY WAS TRENDING ON
TWITTER TODAY, AND IN HONOR OF
ALL YOU DRINKERS-- I AM NOT ONE
OF THEM.
I DON'T HAVE TO DRINK
TO HAVE A GOOD TIME.
SO I JUST WORK SO I'M NOT LEFT
ALONE WITH MY THOUGHTS.
(laughter)
AND ALSO IN CELEBRATION OF PAUL
F. TOMPKINS' FANTASTIC SHOW
"SPEAKEASY" TONIGHT'S HASHTAG
IS CELEBRITY BOOZE, CELEBRITY
BOOZE.
SO EXAMPLES MIGHT BE ST. PAUL
GIAMATTI GIRL, OR MIKE TYSON'S
HARD LEMONADE, OR YAKOV SMIRNOFF
ICE.
(laughter)
IN RUSSIA, ALCOHOL DRINK YOU.
(cheers and applause)
YOU GUYS CAN PLAY ALONG AT HOME
BY TWEETING YOUR HASHTAG
CELEBRITY BOOZE TO THE @MIDNIGHT
TWITTER ACCOUNT.
I'LL PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK STARTING NOW, AND GO.
YES, PAUL F. TOMPKINS.
>> SAZERAC GALIFIANAKIS.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS, WELL
DONE.
JULIE.
>> JAGER MAYA ANGELOU.
>> Chris: POINTS!
YES, PAUL F. TOMPKINS.
>> CLARK GREG NOG.
>> Chris: POINTS!
I LOVE SHIELD, YES, BARON.
>> YOKO DISARONNO.
(laughter)
Chris: YOKO DISARONNO YOU
DIDN'T, POINTS.
YES, PAUL F. TOMPKINS.
>> MARTINI LISTER JUNIOR.
>> Chris: POINTS!
YES, BARON.
>> TYLER PERRY'S HOUSE OF
CHAMPAGNE.
>> Chris: IT IS, IT IS.
HE'S A VERY WEALTHY MAN, POINTS.
YES, JULIE KLAUSNER.
>> ZIMAYA ANGELOU.
(laughter)
IT'S LIKE ZIMA...
>> Chris: YES, PAUL, PAUL.
>> GARY OLD FASHIONED MAN.
(laughter)
>> Chris: POINTS!
YES, BARON.
>> LONG ISLAND ICED TILA
TEQUILA.
>> Chris: WELL DONE.
WE ALSO WOULD HAVE ACCEPTED
LONG ISLAND ICE T.
IT WAS RIGHT THERE, MAN!